[Music]
are you tired of high gas prices
if only you had an ocean of gasoline
well now you do
in this episode we'll fill all our
oceans with gasoline instead of salt
water
how soon would this gasoline ocean be
set on fire
what would happen to fresh water
and why would gasoline oceans destroy
global trade
this is what if and here's what would
happen if the oceans were made of
gasoline
we use a lot of gasoline
in 2020 americans alone used about
465 billion liters just at the gas pump
and we don't just use it for powering
our cars
we add gasoline to chemicals plastics
and other synthetic materials that we
use every day
and because we burn so much of it we
produce a lot of human-made carbon
dioxide
we're already dealing with the extreme
weather and natural disasters brought on
by warming our planet
so
how much worse would it get if our
oceans were made of gasoline
oceans full of gasoline might seem like
an explosive disaster waiting to happen
but our oceans wouldn't all go up in
flames
by itself liquid gasoline doesn't burn
but when gasoline vapor mixes with air
it becomes a flammable gas
every fuel needs to reach a specific
temperature to give off vapor this is
called a flash point
unfortunately gasoline has a very low
flash point
it only needs temperatures of minus 40
degrees celsius to produce vapor
and since the earth's average
temperature is 16 degrees celsius
you'd see oceans of liquid gas that were
constantly evaporating
so although the oceans wouldn't go up in
flames their surfaces would
beachfront properties would be looking
out over a vision of hell
and as the oceans burned there'd be an
incredible surge of toxic smoke
carbon dioxide carbon monoxide and
nitrogen oxides would fill the air
climate change
would accelerate even more
marine life would die instantly so say
goodbye to seafood and because oceans
create half of the oxygen in the
atmosphere
you'd have difficulty breathing
yeah instead of oxygen you'd inhale
toxic chemicals
carbon monoxide would be especially
hazardous
it would replace the oxygen in your red
blood cells causing severe tissue damage
and if you live close to the ocean you
could die from breathing in too much
carbon monoxide
there'd also be issues from long-term
exposure to toxic gas
all over the world people would start
having tremors seizures and
hallucinations
some would experience memory loss
and it wouldn't end there
gasoline is only 75 percent as dense as
ocean water so gasoline oceans wouldn't
have enough buoyancy for ships to float
and because transport ships wouldn't be
able to
well transport stuff
oceans of gasoline would destroy global
trade
and that would increase the cost of
everyday items
okay here's the question i know you've
been waiting for
would it rain gasoline
well gasoline is made up of various
hydrocarbons which all have different
properties
when they turn into a gaseous state the
hydrocarbons separate and disperse
so
you wouldn't see gasoline rain but you
would see rain composed of separate
hydrocarbons
and this would cause our skies to rain
acid
that's because the gasoline oceans would
emit sulfur dioxide and nitrogen oxides
they would mix with water and oxygen in
the atmosphere and fall as acid rain
and that would be bad because acid rain
would damage plants and crops creating
food
scarcity but even more important than
food is fresh water
and that would be hard to come by
any fresh water that flowed into the
ocean would instantly become
contaminated so we'd have to build a
closed loop cycle of fresh water to
sustain life on earth
now would anything good come from the
oceans turning to gasoline
well
the price tag at your local gas station
would plummet
but i don't think it would be worth our
entire planet being covered in toxic
smoke or food and fresh water becoming
scarce
not to mention you'd be battling skin
and respiratory illnesses
now you might fare a little better if
the oceans were filled with liquid
mercury instead of gasoline
but
that's a story
for another
what if